From New York City,
Manhattan,
midtown.
Um,
I grew up near the United Nations.
And how has it shaped me?
Um,
I think it's given me an urban
sensibility,
if you can say such a thing.
Uh,
which means that I feel really
disoriented and uncomfortable in the
countryside and much more comfortable
and cities and m would rather go to a
second or third tier New York City,
then I wander out in the wilderness for
a long time because then I would get
scared.
I think,
uh,
I'm,
I'm one of those city people that is
comforted by the sounds of the city,
like ambulances and a car alarms,
people screaming,
uh,
crazy people screaming in the middle of
the night.
And,
uh,
I,
I do love,
I actually do love going.
Uh,
I spent,
I went to sleep away camp in Maine and
I,
that was really an ideal like time for
me.
Uh,
so,
but I tend to go back and forth between
both extremes.
Right now I'm in there.
I think it makes me,
uh,
pretty scattered often when I'm in the
city in New York.
And,
uh,
when I,
when I'm,
I'm constantly moving around and doing
things,
it's a lot more difficult to find time
to think and concentrate and have any
kind of sustained thought.
Um,
so ideally I guess I'd like to go live
back and live between the city and
country,
but I never have really done that.
I,
I sometimes went to friend's country
houses,
but when I was growing up,
but I never had one.
Uh,
but I guess it makes me pretty scattered
and a have a bad memory and prone to
speaking and articulately.
He's a main contributions.
I think the city.
I love living in Brooklyn and
most of my friends were there and it,
there's a sense of neighborhood.
I live in Cobble Hill.
And do you see people on the street that
he recognize?
Um,
and don't talk to,
cause that would be weird,
but did you recognize them?
And,
uh,
it's,
it has a,
I really like feeling,
uh,
being part of a neighborhood with some
history and the part of New York where
I'm from in midtown has been,
um,
torn up and,
and mixed around.
And,
and the people who live there are people
who weren't there when I was there when
I grew up there.
And,
um,
the buildings have totally changed the
level of magnitude.
Uh,
when we're,
when I grew up,
it was a lot of buildings,
like in the neighborhood I live in now,
three,
four story buildings.
And now there are 90 story residential
apartment buildings.
Um,
and it's,
it's not a friendly place and I feel
like a much more comfortable,
uh.